[Music]
happy Tuesday everybody it's a day to go
fast I guess I can't even hear myself
can you hear me I got you
okay I think it's the the sonic helm hat
thing but anyways I'm Eric that jean-luc
what's up everyone we are checking out
sonic mania do it just came out today or
you know last night depending on how you
look at it and we met Espen le reviewed
it gave it a 9 and it's a solid game
generally you beat it and you could
probably just speak more to the game
than I can so what's new and what what
can we expect I guess yeah so if you're
familiar with the Genesis games it plays
pretty much exactly like those like
physics and everything I remember um a
lot of people remember
Sonic the Hedgehog for that like weird
yeah yeah like they were look like
Donkey Kong sprites and stuff so a lot
couldn't complain about that one where
it didn't have the right physics didn't
feel like Sonic the old games this one
that actually like feels exactly like
the little games having played them
recently it's a it's a there are twelve
zones which is pretty large amount that
might be the most I'm trying to think of
how many when you combine Sonic 3 &
Knuckles
yeah yeah they're like how much that is
but it's about that's a lot I'm not sure
exactly how many are remixed and how
many are brand new I don't know if it's
a 50/50 split we could take a look
alright
but the remix stages are pretty good
like they actually change up the the
stages like a lot more than you'd think
like it does is not what a one-to-one
recreation of those original stages
gotcha
and then the new stages are actually all
really really good alright let's do it
let's go fast
what's up mcj storms Billy the cat says
why is John Luke now Eric also wearing a
sonic hat too will we have one also man
was hit a mistake it is so hot wearing
this thing and
yeah you know what can you do okay so
the stream we have you see here okay we
have one queue so let's see the screen
heel stone that's new that's old that's
new that's old that's old that's new 9
that's old and that's old 11 that's
[Music]
Cameron
okay know it slow TMZ baby seems 50/50
ish the most part I guess we'll just get
right into it here all right let's do it
are you doing anyone I'll do new ones
okay opening all right should I play as
no you pick your poison I'll start with
Sonic and Tails all right now but good
want a classic duo we'll get into it oh
yeah I remember this yes I grew up one
in Genesis I didn't have a snez so I
played Sonic one two three a lot growing
up kind of brings back the nostalgia for
me and it's nice to hear that it's I
like like you said there's levels
potentially 50% of the levels are you
know kind of remixed they're solid you
know it's all like two remixes of those
levels and then there's some also newer
levels
so and yeah and this is $20 it's only 20
bucks that's pretty crazy
yeah and there's a lot of replay value
to this like there's reason to you know
characters there's all the different
modes and alternate abilities you unlock
gotta get all the chaos emeralds which I
haven't done yet so I need to do that
cool and like there's like time attack
you said there's a like a competitive
mode we could race if we wanted to so
I'm guessing white Sonic's on in this
one white Sonic
but I'm sorry I call it white on like
saving time yeah maybe because in the
other games you had to get all the Chaos
Emeralds factory that haven't dropped
them all so I would pursue so right
maybe chat knows I don't know if chat
knows if you guys played enough of it
yet but if you know super Sonico
somebody's already gone all the chaos
idols by now okay definitely I guarantee
it
I need that Super Saiyan Sonic that was
like one of the coolest things as a kid
one thing I like is this you get a new
ability called the drop - John pulled it
down
nice so no more just kind of like having
to run forward to build up momentum of
event yes it's really useful when you
want to just kind of keep things moving
sometimes avoid enemies good thing you
got that yeah
vulnerability but hey guys I just so you
know I'll be mainly monitoring chat edge
John Luke play on sanic gets a big giant
ring at a Chaos Emerald get a Chaos
Emerald
what's up but Joey the new their new
state their new bonus stage which is
kind of like reminiscent of a sonic are
you remember that game and it's pretty
fun um I'm gonna go on record and say i
think most sonic bonus stages aren't
actually fun to play okay I actually
like playing this thing nice get those
blue orbs or bubble things um let's see
why Sonic is gold to ask Gucci right I
guess you could say that he was like a
yellow yeah he's more yellow I don't
know Super Saiyan it is Super Saiyan
yeah that's a nice s J Prince Edward
Prince Edward because why not twice hey
guys you had to buy this game on the
switch a shop yes yeah there's no uh
like physical versions where is the
version I was kinda hoping there would
be because I like the look of the boxer
but no oh but there is physical for Xbox
one and ps4 right nope just that what
was in the collectors and just like with
the code and a bunch of other stuff
which does kind of make that I would
have liked like a limited edition
physical release maybe something that
looks like a Genesis box would have been
really cool maybe a ventures we'll see
something like that I guess I'll just
pimp it anyways cuz the lobby is gonna
happen tomorrow I'm gonna spoilers the
giveaway because it's Sonic anyways and
it related so tomorrow on the lobby will
be given away Sonic mania Xbox one
collector's edition so if you're keen on
trying to get that again I'm assuming
that's why us only so sorry to our
internet well folks watch out
what's up a Sam how are you doing me and
John Luke are doing well he's hopeful
gonna do even better right here once he
kills the spiky ball boss
so you said most of the bosses are
pretty good somewhere kind of easy yeah
some reason some are hard that's
actually very par for the course with
the older Sonic games like when I was
playing those for my history of Sonic
video some of them it's like okay I
could just repeatably like over and over
and you can kind of like stunlock them
almost to a degree and then other ones
are our temper so it feels pretty
similar to that that is a good segue if
you guys are curious about Sonic and how
sonic has progressed over time and
evolved over time
Gianluca has a nice meaty history of
Sonic it's about 15 minutes go see like
all the games right yeah yeah not the
mobile games okay it's the only things I
don't cover whatever you guys love
mobile games then you know
oh don't worry people told me that they
people let me know did they yeah there
are the mobile actually a lot of
comments about that so hey if enough
people on it made only one sometime
Sonic mobile games history of not for
now I need a break I need a break from
Sonic I know but yeah you also have
another history of coming out tomorrow
yep we like to say just look out for it
I've said it oh you have okay it's
uncharted it'll be an uncharted one so
check out wait for that because lost I
guess it comes out next Tuesday okay yes
it's next Tuesday correct and also if
you guys haven't checked out the review
for Sonic mania again we gave it a 9 but
you should check it out man definitely a
review which I edited nice put a lot of
love into oh my boy Robotnik yeah so
like Nick I robotic yeah like mecha
Robotnik from - they put him out like
the you know first major boss
kind of fun the great gamer says can you
do a complication between the two yeah
John Luke did ask me earlier Kevin I'm
late at all really bad it would be
don't worry screwed don't watch this
gameplay just so good you got one ring
means you can still get hitting multiple
times ok ok oh no as long as you get the
ring whoops any to focus I'm like nah ez
game ez life ok boom nailed it there's
nothing about Sonic is it's kind of easy
to cheese it we're like as long as you
get that one ring you're like I just
matter if I get it exactly so I did not
do that very well but that's alright I
didn't do it
you did it that's why you know why not a
10 that's hard to say Prince Edward
you'd have to ask Matt s Pinelli
I didn't review the game so 1 out of 10
so I think his um I know
his major complaint well his only real
complaint he had was that the like cool
alternate abilities you get which I only
have one so far you in order to play
with them you have to play them with a
new save so you can't just like pick and
choose whatever level you want to mess
with them which is kind of a little
unfortunate and then at least for me
well I do really like these remix levels
I would like to see more original stuff
mm-hmm and it I mean I don't I don't
know I don't know the developing process
but part of it it feels like it's the
case of like they're trying to get
people into it right yeah get you back
like it's like probably been a while
since you played just kind of Sonic you
know it's probably good to get you get
your feet white again but the same time
here's here's another question right so
like if we're guessing right we're
guessing that about half of the levels
or half of the areas are new yeah right
do you feel like that would have been
enough of a game that's a good point um
maybe I mean and was that new stuff like
new enough for you oh yeah the new
stuffs great okay your stuffs all really
good it's really inventive it's just as
good there's no weak levels in this game
at all like I could definitely think of
other Sonic games so it's like oh man
like that level that was
IIIi didn't find any of these week they
all felt really really strong um I'm
that's a good point though that I don't
maybe it was because they felt like it
so they could have enough content to
make it worth it I mean that's why the
only thing right the charge maybe ten
bucks instead mm who knows but I I think
they have proven themselves that they
the new levels are really really good
and if they make another one of these
which I bet you they will I think they
could unleash a betting man well he will
he get out of this water though yeah
we'll see and armed purple water I think
they'll make all new levels or at least
that's what I would like oh I miss that
up good now nope nope still good messing
this up bad does it giving me like a
little squish yeah that still happens in
this where you get like unfairly just
like yeah what happened yeah you get you
look like you got hit there right but
right that still happens so weird quirks
like that from the older sound of games
that isn't even moving quickly that's
true it is sonic you guys need to go
faster
yeah actually please don't cuz I got I
got to read it okay okay we're good
what's up DJ e1 good to see you
okay we got this I hope this sells more
than sonic forces 2d sonic is the best
is Kimura ketsu I hope this sells well I
mean I'm not necessarily like I want one
game to fail over the other but I just
want to make your own sanic film I do
want this game to sell really well so
that they keep making making another 2d
making them and don't you know don't
mess it up Sega but it seems like most
people are having a lot of pine words to
say about this one so I don't really see
much negativity around the game you were
saying that there were some issues
people are having with the switch um I
have an experienced yeah so some of this
stuff that I saw in like one of our like
musi chats is that it's kind of like
some oh he caught you yeah there's like
some slowdown in handheld mode and then
like like it's kind of hard to get to
like the home screen and again this
isn't this is like did actually have
that where I hit the home button and
yeah okay that actually there's some
some small issues with that and I think
something with like I think Joey was
trying to like turn off is like you know
a switch or like you know kind of lock
it and it didn't do it like kind of like
right away so there's kind of some small
stuff going on in handheld mode maybe
but it seems like it's kind of a little
case-by-case play I didn't have his load
our hearing and I was playing a bunch
this morning okay and I thought it was
great like it ran you know solid 60
looked good
I don't playing wise I haven't heard
anything it was more of like the getting
to the home screen yeah I did I did have
that though that's a minor enough thing
though that doesn't really yeah it's
probably just more of like an annoyance
kind of thing it's at least it's not
affecting gameplay and things like that
what's important and if you guys are
having any of those issues to onion on
the switch at all I can help move it
feel free to chime in and chat okay so
here's a great example of a remix so the
first area felt very much like classic
come to numb right so for act 2 they
introduced you can turn all that
horrible stuff into jello and then you
bounce on it oh wow the gimmick above
this level and that is a play on it
tails so that is something that I think
all of the older levels are kind of
remixed with these new mechanics that
are really fun and then every level just
feels like it has a new mechanic it's
constantly throwing new stuff at you and
every level like feels really inventive
hmm and because it's um you know they're
so short it's just like it keeps a nice
little pardon leg yeah like the pace is
really good that's why I think the
switch version is such a cool idea
because you know the levels are short
enough that it's like such an easy thing
to just like pull it out on the go and
play and it's something like this is a
kind of game that like are pretty good
for handheld I feel like something you
want to play on the go and like you said
the shorter the level is that kind of
easier it is even to kind of like just
build upon that because it's like okay I
finished a level cool like I just got to
my bus stop or something yeah oh yeah
when I when I came in I was like aw I'll
quickly play a
act and I was like well I'll just play
let's play one more just one more
the old one more I'm actually like I
think like 3/4 of the way done with that
way like it so much
it's interesting how much quicker you
can you can beat the game once you point
you kind of know all the little things
but that's cool about it like that so
that's such a rad thing all right there
we go yeah I mean you like it enough
that you had beaten the ps4 version but
you're like once they come down switch
I'm totally doing that thing yep
yeah and that's the version I'm playing
right now sure sure
we are currently playing on ps4 norman
Jimenez but we have you know a lot of
the that one guy said there's a decent
amount of people in the office that are
playing this which version I know Joey
probably is
Robin why Robin I know Matt was playing
it just to make sure it was good yeah of
course certainly a good time to for
something to come out on the switch to I
feel like oh yeah and there's definitely
good stuff on the shop but I mean at the
same time it's kind of like the waiting
for the Mario waits for that Mario
exactly how ok you got seven rings back
someone saying about some abilities yes
so some of the unlocks are like fun
callbacks to abilities and stuff in the
other games like unlock the super peel
out from Sonic CD which replaces the the
the the new ability the jump jump - yeah
big tails for confirming that
also the stages should feel really big
compared to those originally I mean like
it feels like we've been going on this
one for a while now and I remember at
least you know the older Sonic's it was
like okay we're there already not only
that there's there's a lot of alternate
routes
oh so you could kind of get there in
more than one way yeah I guess we're
going this way
very alternate oh this is cool so this
is um the boss for though you're playing
for yo-yo which is if people remember
dr. Robotnik's mean bean machine that
was basically a Puyo Puyo clone so hey
I'm gonna play awesome doctor yeah this
is so cool
like this like this game yeah yeah I
would just play this mode yeah I wish
this was like just Joshua Waldman said
you also unlock mean bees hey like the
Destiny to beta updated sick why cuz
it's still available I guess so I mean
the next beta is gonna be PC yeah did
you hear me say about the unlock we're
not joshua wall min said you also unlock
mean bean you do oh that's rad perfect
okay let's try and mean bean extra I'm
not doing well here you're not doing
fine this kind of like the the Street
Fighter puzzle fighter where like you do
you can do links like if you dropped
that yeah or I guess that's not a
foreigner yeah oh okay yeah there we go
the triple and suck at Robotnik yeah
yeah we did it for the trophy oh he's
got to be dead here hey okay what about
this oh my god he's cooked oh he's so
cooked this isn't a very hard boss is
playing meant to be cool so when you
have those great ones right like if you
ever gave me great ones you have you had
to work around that I guess like the
other ones blow those ones up
yeah it's so if you pop if you pop a
combo that's attached to one of those
it'll break
greetings Norman from Switzerland thank
you for tuning in we appreciate it
and ratha Vanya does kind of suck that
there's no physical release but hey 20
bucks yeah would you rather it be 40 to
get a physical coffee hey go to your
install - I should turn them you got
some hot notifications baby I'm
downloading a vacation here's what the
new stages thanks to opposites looks
cool pretty cool the classic so that
would that have been an alternate way I
think so see if I can find some
alternate paths I haven't done before
all right do it
look checkpoint oh we going fast oh just
kidding mildly fast
what's up Abby Smith thanks for tuning
in on the youtubes appreciate all of you
guys hanging out with us we stream every
day at 11 a.m. tomorrow will be the
lobby of course no pinball level no
pinball level oh that's a shame it has
an unlockable no metal sonic here right
I know Metal Sonic shows up oh he does
how do you - because someone says they
still don't know how to play the game
how to - oh how to do the spin - you
hold down and then you tap the jump
button to the charger feel like I'm I
got trolled they're going but I figured
just in case I'll happily help out
someone Ishmael Oliver is basically also
helping confirm you can do a drop - by
when you jump hold the jump button right
when you start to go down yes so
remember this from Sonic 3 this is a
bonus tip from that game this doesn't
really remember this so this doesn't get
you the Chaos Emeralds this gets you the
the coins for the secrets yes Liz James
this is essentially cam 4 of the lobby
that's pretty mean to say Jeremiah but I
thank you for tuning in I guess Dena is
this coming up yes it's coming up a week
later there were some issues with it
that they said they wanted got higher
now because uh nice work there was a
mini kiss game says he can't wait for PC
yep for me yeah we needed an extra week
for polish maybe this way was a good
save that you did there just now okay
yep I'm getting wildly dizzy yeah but
it's okay
I'm gonna get it yeah nailed it
those are hard those are really hard
yeah I mean you only really have that
one that looks like it might get sticky
but the rest of them were pretty okay so
we got a unlock we won't know what it is
until after I quit out but yeah you can
check that out later
what's up Korean Tom thanks for tuning
in devin henderson says the metal sonic
fight was awesome it is yeah it's pretty
good you sneaky bastard Eggman in this
one yeah well mr. Eggman we're on that
Japanese cannon now
by the way this is from Norman do the
circumference of the blue balls that
turns all of them to rings what what do
the circumference of the blue balls that
turns all of them to rings I should have
read that before actually ready oh yeah
yeah when you're doing that stage you
can turn them to rings oh okay
nope okay tails made it man okay what's
up Randy a lemonhead what's up ah get
light bulb that light bulb as a studio
Mike see you only I should know that
sonic CD has the pinball level says
Martin NCS music nocopyrightsounds
yes I could shout out your friend true
man 27 shout us to your friend I shout I
see bikini and Eggman Club spin ages
messed that up I was like ooh he almost
fixed it oh we make a popcorn steak a
sonic popcorn it's also a thing visit I
want to say that's a people I remember
when that got first shown people were
saying whoa we haven't beamed through
the satellites our Sonic and Tails in
love yet no you know for the longest
time I thought it tells was a girl
because he's voiced by like a like a
four-year-old everything so I just
thought tails was a girl and and
everyone's like not tells the boy I'm
like light surprised trapped sorry and
anime reference guys Oh glory owned
Eva's if I said your last name right
said I just wish they would make a sonic
maker I mean that's how these guy the
guys who made this game are bunch of
Sonic fan creators who may have been
like making sonic levels for years and
they basically made their own engine
that was capable of recreating like
custom Sonic levels so essentially
that's kind of what this is is like this
is a this basically built on like a fan
made like sonic creator well like you
said though like you're hoping through
the success of Sonic mania that you know
there
they're capable and allowed to make more
other 2d game or 2d games with new ideas
and absolutely yeah well see Oh boss
here yeah robots earlier this guy turn
up this boss music
sonic never loved Amy no their whole
dynamics
this one's tough all right you had a rib
cheese we'll run it back we got three
lives
no problem we'll run back
[Music]
what's up shadow pokemon trainer and yes
this is the first new level that we've
seen so far on the stream thanks for
tuning in I would definitely show off
some new levels dang it
alright you got no rings good luck is
there nice
oh he dodged it or did he need some ring
there we go
how many cameras do you have so far we
got one starting to three yeah I think I
never got like two and you are slacking
when I played through this look is hard
that way you're doing on the switch
mainly now or recursion yeah trying to
get all the castles I'm replaying it and
I get those
yeah we can play some knuckles in a
little bit absolutely he's got that like
new glide thing like - please had that
or sorry well you can use it rather I
honestly didn't play that much snuffles
even though I thought he was like really
cool I don't know why oh he's on it
Norman he knows just about executing the
resume yeah oh I know
okay one more so as a four-year-old did
you think that tails was as foxy sorry
tattoo how long it take you to get them
the miles per hour joke
it took me way longer than I think if I
took me a long time
what is up one of course II know all
right
suck it Eggman do they mostly remix the
music the most part I guess I mean this
is this is completely well this yeah
this is new but for like the other older
stages yeah yeah yeah they're they're
remixed versions of those older music
nice is a good remix yeah damn you
3-ball guy what's up RAM kit are you
doing
[Music]
dang angle [ __ ] sonic was never good -
IGN oh yeah video no I I think sonic has
been good if he were to ask me I think
Sonic Sonic 3 & Knuckles is the best of
the older Sonic's I think it's not like
one was good at the time but I don't get
[ __ ] up particularly but this isn't
that is this now your best I think is I
think this is about Sonic
I think this surpasses all right no way
whatever and even known once you said
honestly a big thing that makes me so
much better is just the fact that it's
in widescreen now mmm true and that it
because it's not running I'm Genesis
Hardware which would definitely like dip
we're playing Wheel of Fortune it would
uh this game this runs out like a smooth
60 grand
oh I think I said Eggman higher TV honey
things that dang Eggman on the LCD
screen
see your keys man
yeah a lot of people I think could
misconceive that tails was a girl all
right good to know I'm not alone
yeah that was a Sarah when I was a kid I
thought tails is a girl like I said hey
wait what updated though you want to uh
I think I'd rather have having me some
sonic mania right now relive some oldies
but goodies and then also get some new
new stuff yeah mad enough speed sonic is
too fast not there he wasn't James
Cornwall the fast pace of sonic is more
fun than Mario because Mario is too slow
either I think they're total apples and
oranges one of those things I get why
here we go
now there's like that war between them
back in the day the companies but really
when you compare the two days I messed
up you're screwed messed up short-lived
do you remember tales his full name
tails miles per hour
I think it's miles tails Prower yeah
they got yeah the shadow Pokemon
trainers has miles tails Prower yeah I
mean it's tough master view but you know
it's better that they hold off having a
PC you know version come out if it's not
ready then instead you'd be playing it
now and complaining that it's pork or
broken or not up to standard right right
right if it's only week I imagine it
must have just been some last minute
weird something something like popped up
on that version man this this hat is so
hot take it off dude
I'm going too fast that's the gimmick
for the rest of this game I'm just gonna
sweat
that's fine Ethan bit saying wiper sonic
game was adventure DX
yeah I'm suck at Eggman
get him what does he even do he does
he's uh
weather weather forecasts there's a
lightning storm oh don't get hit by
lightning son man this Eggman needs to
up his game uh smoke bomb dot exe says
de thing Sega will allow a sequel
absolutely I think they will I think
it's been pretty successful
most of the stuff I've seen review wise
has been pretty positive too we'll see
how it sells but I feel like people are
pretty excited for this and I think
it'll sell well I think having it on the
switch helps a lot too so I also feel
like this is probably relatively low
cost compared to other Sonic games it's
only made by a handful of people yeah
all right at flying battery zone from
three I think it's three right
I can't remember I was so young
that's the problem is playing all the
sauna games recently it's like they all
blend together his certain point what
was that from no idea egg TV has been
canceled the time for now it's been
canceled
Darrell Green mess that up
still good I'm supposed to you're
supposed to grab that you guys did the
jams or tuning red-hot are getting hit a
checkpoint they're usually so generous
with that soon it would have actually
been right after that section
yeah I mean I'm it is a little sad that
you guys have too late but again like I
would rather have a working proper
version than something that's
potentially buggy I think that's the
same for them as as much as we don't
like the ways sometimes they are
necessary wise you get some got away for
those hot day one patches all right
he's working on his arm game cuz sonic
never skips leg day yeah it gets wool
supersonic mania would not be shocked
actually
I'd call it Sonic fever Sonic
[Music]
nice nice
if those rings
oh damn you flame Oh
[Music]
Zen Zulu saying it seems to combine all
the best parts of Sonic 3 & Knuckles and
a few elements of Sonic CD yep yeah
pretty much it feels very much like a
direct continuation of Sonic mehron and
Jahan tick if your fiendin for some hot
Resident Evil action because he says if
we're gonna return to the 90s we gotta
be playing that and not this not this
game we have a series called resident
can evil where you can watch Michael
Hardy and former game squatter Marrakesh
go through all the Resident Evil's so we
got you covered there too
[Music]
it's so weird this this year is like the
year of the throwback like they're
returning to their roots right I am
Sonic's going back to 2d Resident Evil
went back to like the older roots you
know more of Yemen's Zelda right gonna
open world like the firs l-dub they
found a way to last attacked Andromeda
whoa was the thing but those other games
you mentioned before that all took not
every game has successfully gone back to
its own words but everyone's trying call
duty it's going back to what we will
have to see that's a beta for that
multiplayer is next week is it yeah um
so we'll have to check that I think yeah
20 bit oh shoot oh yeah oh that's that
one tricky with that
[Music]
buzzes goofball puzzles sir reginald we
are currently playing on ps4 but we
Gianluca actually has it as on switch to
but he's already beat up ps4 so yeah we
are playing so that way I can go back to
levels later which one you can't go back
to previous levels like level select
until you beat the game no I mean you
want that like you want it yeah I guess
we want to be able to have it but what
really the point though I guess so it's
like if you want to at that point you're
just moving on right Darryl Greene
Oathkeeper Roxas 99 blue sphere is bane
of my life
oh we playing like Star Wars yeah like a
crane game Norman Jimenez we're Jimenez
correct me some bonus levels are real
nasty yeah like I said I don't actually
like play most abundant until the sonic
our style one for this game is actually
Jonathan Flores our collector's edition
codes work okay it's not but yeah they
did work yeah I know that for sure
that's there were some in the office so
pretty sure they're fine oh that's a
good point dizzy death mario odyssey
also going back to some n64 play yep so
going back to the roots there except
Mario's gonna throw a hat Mario
so then is the hat Mario or is Mario
anyways that's her yeah getting real
teeth there yeah sorry oh reference to
Star Wars
we just like to have tails around Marlin
you know yeah you can um you can just go
solo right yes you can go solo you can
also do the have him this part isn't
really good for it but you can have to
like pick you up in yeah it's like sonic
to know so they they okay cuz I remember
doing it as on Genesis I just remember
[Music]
you bro I'm not yeah there's nothing
it's just like it's kind of weird it's
it's sort of unreliable so like I don't
let me to fly tails like now cool color
thing actually boss is hard on this one
yes the actor boss on this one is
actually pretty dumb
it doesn't lens might be where I get
stuck I got a second first time I played
out and now for a boss that will destroy
you
we'll see about that I have a big John
Looby thank you he's gonna nail it this
one of the oil ocean act - boss I also
got star on
I don't think you can you have knuckles
as a partner there is a unlock a secret
unlock called and knuckles mode that
makes knuckles a partner and you can do
that with knuckles so you can have two
knuckles and mass then I was telling me
is that they don't change color too so
they're both red so it's actually really
hard to play because you don't know
what's there to get your controlling and
then you fight and it mirrors your
movement right yeah you're like falling
around six it's like wait what it's
pretty funny it's basically two jokes
mode joke mode it's only digital Eric
the dude unfortunately but again only
$20 hey justice updated
how many more things will update you've
got a line lot to go Brittney Nicole
saying I always preferred the mint the
name Eggman I know man with dr. Robotnik
I think Eggman fits like the more
bumbling nature of the character but
like robotic step one like a more
intimidating
[Music]
get smarted I guess oh no we got
Japanese soggy soggy five six seven
eight
tell me if I'm right or wrong doozy
dad's butt yeah thanks everyone for
tuning in we are currently playing Sonic
mania
we gave it or while Matt Espen le gave
it a 9 out of 10 for our game spot aw
and I have wholeheartedly agree and that
video review as well as the actual
review are both on site so if you want
to check that out you should do so ah
that's 30 that no-brainer that was gonna
happen
no that wasn't even a ring thing that
was um that was one of those like
crunches yeah instant ll pinch yeah
sorry all right
you get a ring though hey we needed
those lives for this really hard boss
but yeah and also if you guys want to
catch up on Sonic
and know more about how he's evolved
over time John Luke has done a history
of Sonic that's available on GameSpot as
well as well as YouTube so check that
out if you're curious fifteen-minute
kind of deep dive in a sonic the only
thing that he didn't really cover with
Sonic mobile if there's enough people I
guess that want sonic mobile maybe
you'll be one in the future but I'm
gonna lean towards no any time soon yeah
nailed it
most of the supports of rumble my
controller is not vibrating but bottles
also turned off I don't know yeah I
wasn't soggy five six seven one nailed
it
I can read Japanese sort of you're an
old-school player if you prefer dr.
Robotnik and of course all who missed
that if you prefer yeah I mean I only
ever thought uh you got got you guys did
a Sonic retrospective yeah pretty much
Norman
I can try linking that I have the link
so let me link that in the chat so if
you want to watch that after the
training you can that's the sonic
history of right there that John Luke
works on what the help of Richard's we
click oh yeah
mostly would have not gotten finished in
time without out that was a long one a
50-minute one so there are the good news
about that though on the on the YouTube
front for the history of is that there
are timestamps so if you're curious
about a specific sonic we have
timestamps in there so you can kind of
click anywhere you want to watch it in
sections it is available
well cam Burke don't Dumon if you felt
that song CD and Sonic three are equally
great to you then you're gonna like song
mania yeah oh absolutely
Sonic CD is pretty good especially the
improved port that you get on Steam
which has like widescreen support and
it's actually made by the people who
made this like they're the ones who did
the sonic CD port which is how they got
this gig I go and I kind of go into that
a little bit
people that is try and do this alright
let's we got it this time I need to get
20 eye rings also you want to get next
to life okay okay let's get so hard I
was like man that didn't that seem
doable clearly they need something that
we do here we go blue spheres again well
no I trap myself
are you are you like forever trapped I
mean I have you found all the hidden
bonus rings probably not right hidden
bonus rings now I what's up
Bodhi audience audience I'm gonna go the
audience yep all right all right that's
just a total one right yeah the spider
acted I hate me spiders
[Music]
what uneven Oh that's why we watch the
tail
without launching tails I was like okay
I almost felt like you're gonna get
pinched for some things just add it like
that sonic beer cool I mean you can get
bitched if you uh get underneath the
here we go boom no all right you got the
one ring hype it's gotta be forever one
ring will spank it we're gonna spank him
radula not going good
the savage whale asking hey guys do you
think Sonic Generations game that will
be released could save the sonic
franchise in Pearl in particular and
Sega in general this game no sonic
generated all right what's the question
if Sonic Generations will save the sonic
franchise i mean ii already came out I
think he means the new Sonic horses it's
not forcing yeah I'm gonna go Assad
forces he wrote generations I'm gonna
guess that he means horses what happens
when you read verbatim I think that's
hard to say yeah I don't think their
heads done just like that game cuz now
that you have boom that's dry no problem
suck it to those who doubted them I
doubted myself yeah I fell short one
ring to rule them all that's right I
don't think that they're like oh sorry
divorce this has to do well I think
they're in dire straits or anything
Sega's doing fine then I'm aware of
anyway oh here's a new level called the
press garden zone
alright so what's the new gimmick on
this one you're running on newspaper and
yet the jump timing on Islands
Oh weird
[Music]
so it's like a it's like a newspaper
print job so you have sort of like
conveyors that contrast you along
[Music]
Corvus bonus says sonic horses looks
cringy AF hey man you don't know that it
could be but you get to make your own
sonic gotta make Skyrim sonic keep I can
[Music]
the newspaper print Center is also an
ancient ruin has known have been more
maybe got windows
[Music]
newspapers owned unless you're making a
joke about how like newspapers are like
an ancient relic
imitates shirt Wall Street Journal still
oh pretty important why not that's all I
can really I think there's actually a
lot of people that still read I think
that it's definitely the older
generation I mean the the them throwing
this kind of level there feels like a
throwback to the 90s so we have that you
know TV station yeah like co2 for the
studio office to do operas level
[Music]
Cambridge g-man saying thanks guys for
recognition
the thing with Sonic CD is who is very
polished for its time weird how papers
making there was that other job you made
that didn't really sound like oh um oh
boy for sale sonic forces is basically a
sequel to generations in other words it
will be near great 8sn I mean it is it
is going back to the game playful in the
other generation which is pretty good so
I have hope on that
Fuli there's actually life over there
that was there yeah I saw it on my face
get in there what a tease oh I realize
that what I guess I forget that I or I
forgot or didn't know that Sega owns
Atlas yeah that was a couple years ago
they bought Alice yeah so Mogwai I think
Mogwai was saying that uh persona 5
sales fight yeah plays blue they're
doing the BlazBlue crossover everyone's
doing a crossover this year and then
they're doing the persona dancing games
yeah you want that high panting now I
really want to make uh maybe maybe next
oh wow some of the Hedgehog hi hello
he's on your head yeah I said side with
a hedgehog right there oh man Wow how
are you doing Sonic how's how's your
release day going we also have dairy
this on it I don't know if that's like
Sonic the Hedgehog related
nothing like that spider boss you just
bought now it's got a leg hide and let
him hit the box the middle boxes sure
that double hat the tactic that greed I
like it
jail favorite music from a new stage I
really like the Mirage Selene music is
that far from where we're at now I think
we get to it
pretty soon probably will say oh oh song
is doing good just say no he's doing
good yeah good I'm glad he's not going
fast though he's not typing fast and
chat though so I don't know if he's the
real sonic oh and then the second IQ is
really cool because it all turns to snow
and he's like freezing like a man write
that down there I think I saw he'll skip
pricing I don't know if that was just my
eyes playing tricks on not probably good
it looks like he got frozen
oh the old sonic squish ah only one life
oh that's bad
so do you end up having 13 user
know-it-all now so it'll beat you back
and definitely do the whole zone again
so I have to do the first act again yep
the last save
I love the music the my music from sonic
2 I honestly can't remember I think my
favorite yeah my favorite new musics
maybe Mirage saloon my favorite remix is
because I actually just like the first
one so much is the act 2 of a hydrocity
one of my favourite tracks you can blip
or even bits
he said sonic liberated keyboard typing
I don't know it out his hands as fast as
his feet though good question from
Brittney Nicole sonic why have your
shoes not worn out yet explain this
sorcery special space-age polymer made
by the masses it's like some Captain
America shield his shoes are based off
of the Michael Jackson shoes from bad oh
really yeah
like the design of them and then they're
like what if we just give them santa
claus colors because America loves Santa
Claus that's really why I'm frozen oh
yeah she pees it a break all this stuff
all right perfect
[Music]
remember you can jump on blue sphere
thank you I think Ethan's Thomas you can
jump on the blue sphere I don't know but
oh oh yeah you can do that totally right
in the the bonus stage you can totally
jump that one I totally right yeah
[Music]
sanic is cold play his knuckles we will
oh yeah we do not fret we'll play some
play some knuckles we got time you got
it a good probably like another half an
hour before we end the stream so get
some knuckles in
[Music]
and we had more the cool secret some
walk like a choking dog but we should
hook Matt's copy cambric do monoi lotion
act 2 we mix is godly though yep
that's also very good don't touch that
Eggman box he knows if he did it would
have been on accent yeah all accidental
for playing giant rings got another
extra life Jesus yeah we are on the
floor over I need all right
one legged
oh no yes yes Chuck it's doing just
doing the ninja thing yeah
like trying to be married though
oh he's got a sword what the heck he's
thursday's of all stars at a shootout
spikes I tried to judge one guys I saw
you have dodged the Oh sneaky he has ice
blade place it doesn't take your rings
away so now now okay it's not trigger
nice jump that's weird he's got that / -
that's hey that's not cool
in close
away from this is the waiting game
some are not his stars anymore which is
just awesome how he's normally he's like
frozen goes under the stars
yeah he's throwing like more and more at
the mouth but got him you didn't do it
that time
[Music]
don't worry mr. gamer the PC version
will be out soon enough
yeah in the savage whale we stream
everyday at 11:00 ham Wednesday is the
lobby it's a more of a discussion
podcasting type show but it's also video
livestream where we discuss big news
you know big reviews of games that's
with Mike Rob kalium eternally usually
me and John Luke are in the back
actually so yep
but you'll see us on streams during the
week there someone said that was meh
tonight Oh kind of kinda in a little bit
oh that one person who was a fan of
Sonic CD will like this stage do you
ever play the PSP sonic racing game
sonic rivals Killing Joke 77s I have not
played that even or he was asking
everybody wait Metal Sonic song on this
level alright hmm oh he is on this level
okay
that's why Ethan said that I just wasn't
sure
dick I think after this level maybe we
should do something nuts
yeah I think I might get I think I'm
gonna get a garage saloon after that
okay grab that ring sonic not thinking I
was like oh that's a bounce-back did you
get a haircut a yup and I dyed my hair
blue that is the cost that you have to
pay to be fast Jake you want to be fast
you got to have spiky blue hair when you
achieve that you'll be able to go fast
[Music]
Sonic the Hedgehog told me that in
YouTube jack just now come on
viago no regular sorry if i butchered
last name how many stages does this game
have there are twelve zones with 2x
style so yeah so it's 2024 levels I
guess go fast
don't I think oh we don't even know a
little red anymore that's how fast we're
going it's going so fast too fast and
I'm hitting everything does it matter as
long as you have rings you just go fast
but damn you stop my flow and that's
excluding bonus stages etc right yeah
yeah it doesn't count upon the stickies
there's two types of bonus stages there
is the circular like blue orb one from
Sonic 3 and then there's the like sonic
R style racing one which is brand new to
this game Miss Jane saying brilliant
game so far
[Music]
nailed it and replaying this game is to
like see the alternate paths is so much
fun I can't wait to UM in the older
Sonic games you can look at like maps
where that people like zoom all the way
out I feel like the entire thing I can't
wait till somebody puts out like what
those look like sigh how big things I
probably huge and he doesn't wants to
know is there co-op there is competitive
so that's the only thing that you get
two players all right I think you race
each other so okay also know adventure
it will be on Steam it's just the late I
think a week that wouldn't is the game
they probably found some type of bug or
if you that they probably wanted to
clean up before release so that is where
that is that so you're not fret it will
be out it is currently out on the kiss
for Xbox one and switch right yes not
going fast enough
yeah I don't have the sonic shoes though
I got a I gotta get me some red Santa
Claus sonic shoes I guess I am missing
that part of the attire but I'm halfway
there I'm halfway there
[Music]
[Music]
level of gaming proposing a good
question do you prefer the name dr.
Eggman or dr. Robotnik I'm on the
Robotnik front I think you're on Eggman
right as a kid I was more on Robotnik's
but I think I've kind of grown belonging
over time where is metal sonic shows up
second act Metal Sonic let's see where
are you at
but first we have to go - yeah Yeah
right in chat will you guys prefer egg
man or Robotnik I am curious it seems
kind of 50/50 right now see a little bit
for both oh we in the future
yep
[Music]
that was a kid I always seem to become
Sonic well you can always try like that
one guy that that tried to be sweet and
go super saiyan like a good like was it
like five plus a minute yeah like I
thought he was gonna have an aneurysm Oh
a lot of Eggman now oh another stupid
some Robotnik Robotnik for life it's
basically I guess this is kind of like
what you prefer I think what people are
used to Eggman at this point because
he's been Eggman longer
he's been Robotnik that's right sorry
the sonic we are in the future
Chamorro tattoo saying a lot of Sonic CD
references yep this stage in particular
is to talk to you
whoa whoa whoa Britney I don't know I
didn't do a count yeah you can't say
it's settled team Eggman what's up abby
smith welcome to the dream
[Music]
Oh No are you saying yeah I missed the
Future Passed road jet maximum 90 said I
just beat Sonic CD the other day lol so
is this game a compilation of Sonic
classic games exact some what it does
take levels and elements from every of
the classic Sonic games putting
corporators own new stuff so it's not
quite like a hundred percent throwback
to wait generations was purely a
throwback
it does incorporate a lot of new
elements as well and the new elements
are really good alright see if I can
sanic was actually where I stopped when
I was hanging my slippers earlier see
how I do I'm rooting for metals pony
tails tails is gone
hello tails human shield right back
do you guys work for Sega no we don't
dark sonic plays nope we work for
GameSpot
and rings back
ooh doing like his best and bison
impression name this parts actually no
one knows best 154 are you gonna play
sonic forces when it comes out yes we
will be oh he do use a smart one that
guy
nice timing I like it
oh right over his head oh no come back
to me I struggled this because I wasn't
really figure out what to do once you
figure that out though that part I can't
make them see ya but then oh we back on
the second phase to it phase 2 metal
sonic doesn't just have one phase you
gotta be them twice fair is fair
what happened there Oh king sent by fire
thing is hitting me enough ya need to go
fast young Luffy last day of saying I
hope Saiga resurrects other franchises
if this says well I want Shining Force
and phantasy star i think Saiga said
they were interested in doing more stuff
with their like older catalog of games I
thought that meant just like you know
like we putting them out or actually
making new ones but I know they saw
they're interested in doing something
that wow you got rid of pseudo sonic
real fast
level F gave me saying love these
animations yeah the animations are
really nice like great sprite work Sonic
Brittney Nicole saying just imagine a
Jet Set Radio remain
[Music]
cheap clothes all right yeah I got um
tails pastels and the wall go fast man
tails is bailing you out now Thank You
tails
mr. all might know mr. Oh mr. all night
oh my both we know here oh yes mr. all
mall right I guess need another 2d at
Megaman I haven't played a mega man
since 2x I think that's the other big
one that people are like clamoring for
is Megaman but they have those
collections though they do they do we
don't want like a new one yeah yeah want
a new one
come on oh you're at a ring yeah yeah
yeah yeah you got cheese it she's it
hard all right enemy on the brain that
sounds close on the brain oh one extra
ring this Rando all right
his name is miles okay my bad you're
right octo man his name is miles
there's names not tails miles uh D this
is one great boss yeah pretty good
hydrocity all right let's go to you want
to do some sucking knuckles right
knuckles on that one level you're
talking about yeah easy-peasy says no I
guess so um did you ever watch a song
Academy I did not watch the I wash the
Sonics I am it's a kid but nothing not
the anime one no I never watched it so I
can't say anything and time-attack
you're gonna pick knuckles
yes Red Dead is not out till next year
so there's no point of us watch you guys
play that Wild West online game instead
so uh this stage here is actually
specific to knuckles which is pretty
cool
I got this whole area but just on this
particular act okay
if you Sonic you have like a clawing
section on the plane but they're mine
I'm also I've never played this act so
uh alright we know about it cuz Matt was
telling me about it so we go burning
experiences together seemed like you had
the right idea there maybe I lied to the
right or something I got these things
like keywords yeah nickels got that hot
glide action is it Nick yeah don't say
isn't gonna come on you yeah what's up
eight use good day battle pants one no
no now you playing the game right jabo i
knuckles he can you glide after that I
would assume so right alright you just
wanted to come back for that yeah
totally that's how I see it we saw a
power up oh we're in a gun that's cool
that looks rad ah c'mon I don't know why
the PC versions delayed mr. game where I
just know it's delayed
no there must be some bug or something
it's my guess seems like a safe or
something
[Music]
this guy's a sneaky one
[Music]
yeah so it seems like this level is very
much designed around like for
reliability we are currently playing on
ps4 Randi Segal doe John Luke has been
playing on the switch too though mm-hmm
says it's been pretty good the only
thing that like we mentioned earlier
that we've heard of is there's a little
bit of a thing with trying to go to your
home button that's like slower than
usual and then I think Joey was having
someone kind of minor issue with uh kind
of like locking up the thing or turning
off the power break haven't confirmed
that but no nothing gameplay wise though
so it's been solid otherwise as John
Luke has mentioned earlier who's that
just so good
[Music]
Oh No nap time didn't I that really this
game is pretty solid battle pants 120
dollars currently on Xbox one ps4 switch
gonna eventually be on PC as well Matt s
Pinelli gave it a 9 out of 10 we
reviewed it video review and written
review are both out for your viewing
pleasure if I should check that out
after and as we mention if you were
curious about um more stuff about Sonic
Gianluca has done a history of so he's
done pretty much like every game sans
the mobile stuff so if you want to check
that out that's also on YouTube it's got
a hot timestamps and whatnot so you can
check out the games you want or digest
it you know different parts but it's
about 50 minutes for that history arrow
yep a long one a lot of gaming lot to
cover
well yeah thank you guys all for tuning
in of course we are live every day at 11
a.m. we'll be live tomorrow 11 a.m. with
the lobby where we'll actually be giving
away a collector's edition of Sonic
mania for the Xbox one but unfortunately
I want to say that that's just for the
US so anyone that's outside of the US I
apologize but for those in the US if
you're curious to the lobby and try to
get answers that way there you go nailed
it
I like the stage it's cool yeah there's
a lot of it's definitely playing into
the lake you know my knuckles character
and like the glide ability there mess it
up like that like you said you've never
played this level football yet I barely
play knuckles too so I'm like trying to
get this slide used to that blue
hedgehog oh yeah I like that cool super
Manning
yeah battle pants it seems like a pretty
good one I mean it's got some good
classic remixes of old levels also has
some like new stuff as well so a lot to
check out so there's kind of some
pinball Age stuff going on a little bit
yeah in a way not in the way we would
think it would you're not like an actual
pinball stage
I thought you I almost thought heroes
like oh man you're not gonna lie
printout knuckles can go pretty fast to
go sick no boss huh
not on the Time Attack got it okay so
the Time Attack is the if you just
wanted redo a stage with the character
you can actually do it through Time
Attack once you've gotten beat in the
game but um well I get the boss and
stuff so you have to please you have a
leaderboard yeah is there a leaderboard
hit that trying uh let's find out dang
scram Bo three minutes and ten seconds
free good that's pretty good
- five minutes fine never played it you
can't speedrun a level you've never
played that clock is there anything else
that you want to see at this point I
know what else is uh what else are the
game well well noting that we didn't do
this competition of which yeah grits I
have so it's like the only thing I have
unlocked secret wise is that I can do on
the CD ability the super peel out
instead so if I quickly show that off
yeah
this opening don't you skip it yes the
music is pretty good weird musician as
well as no adventure saying that the
music's really nice don't ask who the
guys on the wide posters they show up as
a boss at one point sonic but I don't
know if they're also reference they
might be references to others
sonic I definitely don't post personify
spoilers and jeez I will definitely get
rid of you I haven't even finished that
games please no loss have lost save
rather sorry I says I wish this game had
a platinum trophy I'd get a no ps4 so ya
can't do the drop anymore can do the
super PR oh yeah infinity you see that I
immediately diamond rings maybe play a
level of miles tails our boy miles do
some tail back cuz then I'd assume you
can fly it yep there no love for miles
man tails does also detect without
breathing call Lisa literally the water
level does anyone remember that 3d Sonic
game on the genesis sonic now thank
Jamis do not I stopped playing after
three
Hamburg dumped do man says I would buy a
handheld version of the Dreamcast in one
second but what would you play other
than like Daisy taxi Power Stone Sonic
Adventure 1 to samba de amigo
maybe Marvel vs. Capcom 2 yeah
playback alright get get your questions
and whatnot that you have left in cuz
why and after this miles level here on
hydro city but uh we do appreciate you
guys all tuning in remember if you
haven't followed like or subscribed we
go live every day at 11:00 and we also
put up cool features like javelins
history of for sonic he's also gonna
have one out tomorrow that's gonna be
uncharted I just got munched yeah I'm
good
so that'll catch you up on in charted
before lost legacy comes out next week
but yeah we really do appreciate you
guys hanging out with us chatting with
us
having debates about Eggman or dr.
Robotnik so drop that pot switch my
Power Stone there was like that one
almost higher stone ish like game if it
goes on PC we have a copy of Power Stone
on the Dreamcast
oh yeah the library no and a Dreamcast
Ellen plays Power Stone hey took it off
the lobby set like the one Dreamcast we
have man I don't waste that on the
Halabi set as answered took the instance
for as well goob the I should bring my
entities before it's literally sitting
in my closet well Ike the problem with
that in support I grabbed him lobby says
I don't think we have any oh I have my
cables yeah mine's literally sitting in
my closet explaining it's salvaged at
this point so actually bring that in
yeah lost legacy is next week we'll be
streaming that on Tuesday I'll probably
asking potentially John Luke sure or
yeah I think it's hit you and Jake
that's probably the most yep bar so yeah
well be battle so reviewing it correct
so we'll be back next Tuesday most
likely with lost legacy is mine my plan
can't talk about it yet yeah we can't do
anything can't saying about that but it
exists you should check out the history
of tomorrow and charted so you guys get
caught up on what is going on prior to
lost legacy although I did see the I
don't know who saw it yesterday but
there was this reddit like things like a
gift
I picked like or like a short-form video
and it was like Nathan Drake predicted
lost legacy eight years ago
and it's because I guess he tells Chloe
like during this like one seems like
you're pretty good this hero stuff you
should do this more often
and she's like hey yeah and it's like
yeah I guess eight eight years later
we're here and it's happening a little
bit I can't I can't yeah game but I see
what they're coming from yeah it's more
just nice that they they brought Chloe
back sort of a fan favorite character
who was absent from from four entirely
like having her bring her back one last
time you know it's a Final Four Naughty
Dog you know close to the book on their
involvement with Uncharted it's nice
[Music]
Oh 1,000 shows differently nope
Ellie she doesn't have the same
breathing problems now I think tails can
breathe underwater you know yeah boxers
can do that yeah longer than hedgehogs
Wow what it's for and gold mine I think
we're on the wrong way
Thanks so so find out what could
possibly go wrong here like you said
alternate routes and I definitely just
looped back yeah
just don't get caught by that thing I've
never been in this part of this exercise
like no ideal I'm going it's all right
you figured it out on the knuckle level
ah here we go figure it out here
these adorable tails animations though
level animations are really nice thank
you
lobster robot batter yeah it just looks
like something from SpongeBob
SquarePants
sorry Oh GameSpot I've got a question is
sonic can turn into Super Sonic and
Knuckles into super pink nipples with
yellow socks and Tails turn what these
tails turn into I got a riddle
knuckles & knuckles Modi I don't have
that unlock he doesn't have that I've
heard I've heard about mouse tell me
about it and it looked amazing but I do
not have it unlocks unfortunately also
sounds really confusing though what or
like yeah because you said you're the
same knuckles and it's like well well
you say you can do with any character so
you could be like Tails and Knuckles and
Sonic and Knuckles but you got to be
knuckles and knuckles and but knuckles
are nothing
oh yeah I'd be real yeah that's what you
want a sandwich real darling joke ah not
the big ring
[Music]
fly your way up immediately super tails
with the help of flicky
[Music]
goal all right all right we did it good
job John Luke so yeah that was sonic
mania out today $20 right sorry about
what was it 12 zones right well both
zones you got time attack you got
competition you know there's lots of
Secrets to find you can play as you know
Sonic and Tails you can play it's just
Sonic just tails not goals like there's
so much in this game like it I think
it's well worth the $20 it's like a lot
of replay value in this game yeah out on
Xbox one ps4 switch and soon also on the
PC in about a week or so I think it's
delayed a little weak but thank you
everyone for tuning in and remember join
us on the lobby tomorrow at 11 a.m.
catch John Luke history of Sonic if you
want to know more about Sonic and its
history of tomorrow for uncharted but we
are out of here thank you guys all for
tuning in we'll check you guys out next
time see you
[Music]